if Donald Trump could shoot somebody in
the middle of Fifth Avenue and get away
with it
what brazenness might we expect from his
fellow billionaire in New York egomaniac
Michael Bloomberg the media mogul gave
us a glimpse back in 2001 while dumping
the first round of 74 million dollars
into his late in life political career
when a reporter covering the New York
mayoral race asked him whether he had
ever smoked marijuana you bet I did and
I enjoyed it Bloomberg bragged talked
about do as I say not as I did during
Bloomberg's three terms as mayor the Big
Apple became the marijuana arrest
capital of the world thanks to the
notorious stop and frisk searches
conducted largely in neighborhoods where
billionaires rarely venture but Mayor
Mike's conscience has never been
noticeably troubled by such obvious
disparities under the law if anything
disproportionately impacting the poor is
a conscious policy choice in a
conversation two years ago
Bloomberg defended his fondness for
taxing items such as sugary sodas and
trans fats that are mostly enjoyed by
the non rich some people say well taxes
are regressive but in this case yes they
are that's the good thing about them
because the problem is in people that
don't have a lot of money and so higher
taxes we should have a bigger impact on
their behavior and how they deal with
themselves the question is do you want
to pander to those people or do you want
to get them to live longer rules may be
important for those people but are much
less so for the eighth richest man on
the planet Michael Bloomberg is the
leading financier of gun control
advocacy in America and one of the few
people allowed to have an armed security
detail when traveling in Bermuda he has
been positively trumpian about releasing
his tax returns over the years snapping
at the mere suggestion that such
political traditions should apply to him
and as recently as January 2019 even as
the rest of the Democratic Party was
finally evolving toward ending federal
prohibitions on the marijuana Bloomberg
once enjoyed he called pot legalization
perhaps the stupidest thing we've ever
done if George W Bush and Barack Obama
assured in the return of the imperial
presidency Trump and potentially
Bloomberg represents a further
devolution toward the impure
Presidency I've got a pen and I've got a
phone and I can use that pen to sign
executive orders and take executive
action there was an audacity in Obama's
pen and phone and there was a whole
theory of executive branch autonomy
dreamed up by former Vice President Dick
Cheney Trump's contribution has been
more vulgar more direct more New York
he's walking out like big high fives
smiling laughing like to punch him in
the face I'll tell you
Bloomberg's manners may be more refined
but only a little
there's the locker room talk about women
which she has already preemptively
apologized for Trump may troll people
about seeking a third term but Bloomberg
actually went there changing New York
City law near the end of his term
limited second term in order to run for
a third and then switching the law back
soon after winning as the New York Times
noted at the time
Bloomberg thinks that being able to
serve three terms in office is a good
idea just not for anyone else
Mike's above the law demeanor might seem
preferable to Donald's base appetite for
corruption but their approaches to how
rules apply to mere mortals are
distressingly similar to Trump
constitutional limits on executive power
are speed bumps slowing down as policy
goals especially concerning immigration
to Bloomberg policy ends justify even
unconstitutional means before very
recently changing his mind on stop and
frisk the former mayor defended it as he
did the New York Times in September 2018
like this I think people the voters want
low crime they don't want kids to kill
each other it seems unlikely that in an
era of resurgent democratic populism
primary voters will reward the kind of
moneybags who has literally appeared in
skits as King Michael
but seeing Bloomberg even in fourth
place continues an alarming trend we've
stacked up so much power at 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue that billionaires
with insatiable ambitions are eyeing
that address greedily and finding market
share among understandably disgruntled
voters lawyer Alan Dershowitz said on
Fox News last year that the president
has the power that Kings have never had
until we start consciously limiting that
power we will continue getting the
Royals we deserve
you
[Music]